みなさんこんにちわはじめしゃちょーです
ベイブレードバーストを遊んでますでしょうか
最近のベイブレードでですねいままでの
ベイブレードと違って戦うと
爆発してパーツがバラバラになったりするめちゃくちゃおもしろいベイブレードなんですけども
ぼくけっこう遊んでまして
けっこう遊んでるうちにですね
そのあるあるというか
ベイブレードバーストやっててよくおきるようなことが
何となくわかってきたので
今回それをちょっと動画にしてみました
たぶんベイブレードバーストで遊んでいるひとは
たぶん共感してくれると思います
ではベイブレードらるるぁる
噛んじゃった
ではベイブレードあるあるスタート（指ぱっちんのおと）
しゃーやろーぜ
しゃーいくぜー
３・２・１
あっ
ごめん
いいよ
しゃーやろー
しゃー
いくぜ
スリーー
トゥー
ワン
しゃーやろーぜ
しゃーいくぜー
スリーー
トゥーー
ワン
Ｇｏ
シュー！（シュート！）
ごめん
いいよいいよ
もう一回やろ
スリーー
トゥー
ワン
Ｇｏシュート
あれ？
しゃーやろーぜ
しゃーいくぜ
スリーー
トゥー
ワン
Ｇｏ
シュート
（キンッ）
（カンッ）
（バラボロォカラカロコロコロォッ）
しゃーやろーぜ
しゃーいくぜ
スリーー
トゥー
ワン
Ｇｏシュート
ごめんごめんもう一回やろーもう一回やろー
スリーー
トゥー
ワン
Ｇｏシュート
ブーーーーーーーーン（ベイブレ―ド）の音
もう一回
けっこうあるわ
あるよね
力んじゃうと
そう
あるよね
（カンコンッ）
ちょっさーもう
時間だから
今日もう帰るわ。
マジ？
もう帰るの？
ちょ　ラスト一回ラスト一回
一回？
ラストラスト
これで勝ったやつが一番強い
あーいいよ
いいよ
しゃーいくぜ
スリーー
トゥー
ワン
Ｇｏシュート
あー　クソー
よっしゃー
ちょっ待って待って
もう一回もう一回もう一回
ラストラスト
ラスト
マジのラスト
マジのラスト？
もう一回
これで勝ったやつが一番強い
時、時間やばい
大丈夫
これほんとラストラスト
しゃー
スリーー　トゥー　ワン
Ｇｏシュート
やべっ　やべっ
あーもうなんかいやっても同じだって
いける　いける
がんばれ
いけるぞ　いけるぞ
いける
あーもー
クッソーー
クッソ　ダメか
何度やっても同じだってもー
ラストラスト
ほんとラストラスト
マジマジ
しょーがねーなー
ガチね
もうこれで勝ったら
ほんとに？
マジ
ほんとに　マジ一番
マジ一番
日本一
本物　本物
スリー
トゥー
ワン　ゴーシュート
これは完全に勝った
ほーらいやいや
完全にほら・・・
あーもー無理
ムリ無理むり
待ってマジのマジのラスト
しゃーやろーぜ
しゃーいくぜ
スリー
トゥー
ワン
ゴー　シュート
あっ
くっそ
強いなー
勝てねーよマジで
いやいやまー強いからけっこうこのベイ自体がね
待って待ってパーツ無えーパーツ無えー
あれ？
さっきどこいった？
飛んだよね
えっマジないんだけど
そこらへんじゃないの
ないないない
ちがう？
えっマジないこれ
やばい
マジやばい
かあさーん
しゃーやろーぜ
しゃーいくぜー
スリー
トゥー
ワン
ゴー　シュート
いたーー
あーやばい
やばい
やばい　目入った
ごめん
やばいやばい
ほんとにやばい
目終わった目おわった
まじやばいまじやばい
まじやばいちょまじやばい
かあさーん
テ〜レ〜テ〜レ〜テ〜レ〜テ〜レ〜テ〜レ〜テ〜レ〜
メロディー書くのメンドクセェ。
だからねぇよw